اذا تدخل الهدنه في السودان يومها الثاني
وافد مراسل الجزيره بتجدد اطلاق النار
صباح اليوم بين الجيش والدعم السريع شمال
الخرطوم البحري هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره
من الخرطوم حيث يخيم الهدوء على العاصمه
السودانيه عموما صمتت اصوات البنادق في
انحاء السودان مع تسجيل مواجهات متقطعه
يوم امس في منطقه الافتيحاب جنوب المدينه
هدنه الثلاثه ايام اذا تنتهي غدا الخميس
ان الخرطوم ما معنى مراسل الجزيره هيثم
اويت هيثم كيف الوضع الان هل مازال الهدوء
يخيم على المكان
الطريقه يعني نعم حاله من الهدوء تخيم على
وسط الخرطوم على بعض مناطقها سوى نسمع من
وقت لاخر اصوات متفرقه ولكنها يعني قليله
مقارنه بالامس وامس الاول هذه الهدنه فيما
يبدو الان هي تمضي بشيء من الهدوء وهي
تعتبر افضل من سابقاتها من الهدن التي
شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه وكثيفه لكن هذه المره
هذه هي الهدنه يعني تمضي و الاصوات تقل
بدرجه كبيره جدا من الاشتباكات وان الناس
الان قد بداوا يتحركون ولو بشكل قليل جدا
من بعض المناطق الى وجهاتهم التي يريدون
التحرك اليها رغم غياب حركه السيارات
والمواصلات ولكن اغلب من رايناهم هنا
يسيرون برجلهم نتيجه للصعوبات التي طبعا
يواجهونها جراء الكاسات هذه الازمه على
واقع الحياه سواء كان هنا في الخرطوم او
في مناطق اخرى عديده هناك حاله من التفاؤل
بان هذه الهدنه التي ستستمر حتى الغد ان
تكون بارقه امل لالتقاط الانفاس وان تتيح
للمواطنين ان يستطيعوا الحصول على بعض
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه وخدمتهم من الرعايه
الطبيه وايضا ستكون فرصه سانحه للعالقين
في مناطق الاشتباكات وفي دائره النزاع بان
يخرجوا من هذه المنطقه خاصه المناطق
المتاخمه للقصر الرئاسي ومحيط القياده
العامه ومحيط شارع المطار هذه هي المناطق
التي شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في الايام
الماضيه طيله ايام هذه الحرب التي بدات
منذ اكثر من عشره ايام وحتى الان ما تزال
الرؤيه النهائيه حول انهاء هذا القتال
غائبه ولكن هذه الهدنه على الاقل تبعث امل
بان هناك استجابه الان من الاطراف
القبول بهذه الهدنه الانسانيه ومن ثم هناك
الان الحديث عن التفكير في تطوير هذه
الهدنه وتحويلها الى مشروع وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار هذا ما يامله البعض تامله
سواء كان الداخل السوداني او المجتمع
المحيط الاقليمي والدولي الذي يسعى الى
وضع حد لهذه الحرب المستعره والتي بدات
يعني تنعكس سلبا على كافه مناحي الحياه من
الناحيه الانسانيه ومن الناحيه الصحيه ومن
ناحيه التدمير البنيه التحتيه على هذا
البلد